here's the breaking news right now
project Veritas CEO reportedly fires all
of the organization staff the nonprofit
has been plagued by internal turmoil for
the last year following the termination
of founder James O'Keefe the official
project FedEx project Veritas X account
that's what was funny X Twitter account
shared the message SOS Hannah Giles just
fired us all such a weird goings-on an
unnamed Source confirmed timcast the
project Veritas staff has been let go
and further claimed the Chief Financial
Officer for the nonprofit has resigned
the source told timcast donations dried
up there was a massive drop in financial
support and the writing was on the wall
for months Jack besobic the senior
editor at human events also said a
source had confirmed the validity of the
message all of production all the field
Ops all of comms all of legal the source
told Pacific according to an online post
only remaining are office admin HR
person a couple development people and
I.T the organization which has been
known for breaking number significant
stories had been plagued by
administrative turmoil this year this is
absolutely amazing to me and predictable
we knew it was only a matter of time the
post millennial also has additional
information uh breaking exclusive chaos
at project Veritas almost all employees
have been laid off and they go on to add
a little bit more here
she came to All Hands in April with her
quiz a quote with her fat sidekick Ben
Wetmore and all they did for three days
was talk-ish about James and relitigate
all the terrible things he did to her
and them 10 to 12 years ago I knew right
then her entire agenda was revenge on
air Talent Christian uh Hartsock James
lolino were both laid off after Giles
told staff that a restructuring would be
underway Caitlin Erickson Jamie Phillips
Alyssa Dayan were also fired the
terminations were done via Zoom call
with HR with a few of those in the New
York office Giles did not make an
appearance she's a lying sack of ish A
source told the post millennial no one
respected her anyway here's what I have
to say about all this
if you still worked at project Veritas I
don't know I've I got very little
sympathy for you they came after founder
and leader James O'Keefe they tried to
strip him of everything he built
and there were people who were party to
the knives in the back of James O'Keefe
who signed a letter calling him out so I
just have to say I'm not calling out
anyone individually because I don't know
who but to all the people who stabbed
James in the back and have now lost
their jobs
I don't know schadenfreude like what
this is what you deserve did you think
that this organization could survive
without the man who built it and was
doing the hard work and making the
sacrifices to keep it up and running
these people firmly believed they were
the ones doing it all and surprise
surprise the moment you betray your
leader
all the money's gone they bring in a
shark who then nukes you
okay yeah it's been a wild year do you
guys remember that coup at project
Veritas the thing that stands out to me
the most is that letter that was signed
by like 16 employees they had all these
uh you know they said that James is a
tyrant he does all these terrible things
they had all these examples one was that
this donor felt like you know he hadn't
been friendly to her or something and
then afterwards that dinner was like
that's not what happened that's not it
at all like he was like short with some
woman and then they were like what are
you talking about James was perfectly
fine he stole a woman's sandwich so this
this group of people that said we can do
it without him thought they could also
hold on to the donors who were paying
for James O'Keefe that's right that that
organ I mean it's called project Veritas
but it was James O'Keefe yeah I mean so
the second he's gone what are you
donating to I mean he was it was his
investigative journalism and tactics
that people were were watching he was
the face of it the second that he was
gone what I just don't understand what
they thought would happen especially so
I mean today I know you said this you
know according to the reporting they
were fired they weren't fine I mean the
bottom line is they ran out of my I mean
I don't know the finances but like let's
stop kidding around once he left it
dried up and at some point they said we
can't pay you anymore Carla would you
win why didn't they lead off with firing
their development team the billions
people are supposed to raise money I
think they have money but I think
money's not coming in
because if you look at their 990s they
had millions of dollars and so what's
probably happened is they probably
looked at the finances and said we got
no donors we got a couple million in the
bank
at this rate we will be right totally
you know we'll be defunct in uh
insolvent in six months so he's like
okay fire everybody now and veritas will
function to some degree for a few years
but you know the funny thing is I I do
believe uh and obviously the the O'Keefe
Media Group uh that that he started
these people bought into a mission okay
they wanted to see see things exposed
without
the project Veritas being any kind of an
alternative which
right now this is actually going to be a
boon for him I think because they're
going to go okay like let's just go back
to basics I mean maybe he stole
someone's sandwich but the bottom line
is but the point is like here's what
we've invested in to begin with let's go
back to the OG yeah I think his the
employees actually that are getting
fired might actually go work for O'Keefe
Media Group and it's like
they might want to go work for okay
Media Group but James he's going to do
his own little investigative journalism
and be like I have a video of you a
tweet from you and an email from you and
you're not working for me it reminds me
of Alexander the Great when he was on
campaign his men just got to the point
where they were fed up we're like we're
leaving and he was like fine leave so
they all he gave a speech and he was
like get out go go home tell him you
left me here and then a couple days went
by and the men like realized what they'd
done and they went back to Alexander and
begged to be let back because they were
starving and lost and maybe maybe he
gave this rousing speech and they all
realized like what they would be really
be leaving and here's here's what a
speech is pretty incredible and so he
took him back he took it's like you're
all my brothers this this reminds me uh
this has a touch of the uh an element of
leftism entitlement arrogance James
O'Keefe starts this organization he
sacrifices he gets raids raided by the
feds he gets sued over and over again
he's the the tip of the spear he's the
he's the front face uh the the front man
of this organization taking all the Heat
and working non-stop he brings people
onto a system at some point they get in
their minds that he's the bad guy and
they should take over and that they'd be
fine without him
and then it all comes crumbling down you
know what I find vaccinating by the way
so many times organizations uh like the
one that James founded you hear the
founder at some point starts to grift
they steal they get too big for
themselves that was never the case under
him as big as they grew as much money as
they brought in there's not I mean to
your point like this is a nitpicky thing
that they went after him on and I don't
know all the claims but it was never
about stealing or living the high life
or buying expensive cars and a couple
things were okay yeah they claimed it
like he paid his own wedding or
something like that but but okay and
again I'm not but some of these
organizations are are get to that point
where they it topples on itself he
stayed true to the mission
right and I think that that that sort of
is an interesting thing for me to watch
because then he goes and does O'Keefe
Media Group and it's like all right and
he seems to have at least getting back
to getting enough people to help fund
that but I I just find it funny that
these guys thought that they could do it
without him yeah if you have a heart
issue don't rip your heart out I mean
that's the you got to heal the thing you
know have James sit down earlier point
if they're trying to keep this thing
going for a year or two you know you
fired your entire content team like the
people who are going to do the
investigative journalism which is
theoretically what people were donating
to support in the first place now you
have what an HR person and more people
fundraise like there's nothing there you
have lost sight of your mission they
they they're wearing Veritas like a skin
suit and everyone can see right through
it if that's just it if James had been
like I'm gonna leave if it was his
decision and he was like everyone
continue to support this creation that
I've been a part of I think it would be
fine I think people would have stayed on
yeah but they stabbed him in the back
and a bunch of people who worked there
signed a letter stabbing the in the back
despite the fact the letter said some of
us haven't been witness to any of this
nor have we ever been wronged by James
O'Keefe but we're signing the letter
anyway and it's like oh I was waiting
for this moment for for these people to
get their their comeuppance
I wonder how many of them do you think
James will hire any of them some of them
I bet some of them are probably just you
know like I don't have no idea I I bet
some of them are still encounter with
James with James saying I'm so sorry
this happened people who didn't sign
that letter accusing him of wrongdoing I
gotta tell you if I worked for Veritas
and I was uh you know out with James
whatever reason and I bought myself the
most delicious chicken bacon ranch
sandwich and James walked up and says I
haven't eaten all day I need your
sandwich dude I'd be like bro no problem
I'd be like you're you're busting your
ass you're working really hard I will go
get another sandwich the idea that they
signed this letter of abuse because he
he allegedly took a sandwich I'm just
like you people are so petty that's the
that you know what man I'm glad that he
was able to get out and I'm I am glad
that he was able to start I believe I
believe OMG is a for-profit yeah of an
entity now good yeah now he has see the
problem with a non-profit first of all
James deserves as much money as he he
decides for the work that he does and
with a non-profit that they actually
you're limited right you have to when
you're filling out paperwork you have to
uh sign how much people are going to get
paid are going to be are there gonna be
any employees who make more than six
figures and I think the 990s showed that
James was getting around 300K per year
leading a what were they like an
eight-figure organization some of the
most influential with some of the most
vital and important groundbreaking
reporting the Amy rohrback story on
Epstein and here's James O'Keefe getting
you know uh like a mid-tier like VP
salary level which is hey it's good it's
I'm not coming out right 300 000 years
but the level of influence and work that
he did he should decide if he wants more
but more importantly if James wants to
buy himself a Lamborghini I hope he does
he deserves it but as a for-profit
organization James can without any
question without any board members
without any legal paperwork choose to
hire whoever he wants fund whatever he
wants to launch documentaries do all of
these things and it's much much easier
and much much more effective for him to
do this he doesn't have to worry about
now so they accuse him taking too many
black cars night and vehicles to and
from and I'm like yeah people want to
kill this guy the least you can do is
give them an Uber you know between
locations and they're like no it's
wasting money he's not like an executive
at St James he needs more protection but
but get back to the none of this the
donors are giving it to because of him
yeah right this is not like they
installed this guy and said wow we
brought you into this organization he
built it he's getting there the donors
are buying into him and his work
so if he wants to take a car here or
there to your point Tim about safety and
just efficiency Comfort yeah but this is
not again this isn't it's not like
they're like by the way he was taking a
G5 you know from from DC to his place in
the Hamptons this is I want I want a
black car that I know that the driver is
going to be safe that I'm gonna this is
not excess I just this is the benefit of
a private organization uh having a
private entity James will not be
scrutinized for saying hey we have so uh
he came out here a couple times and in
order to do so they had to do a private
Charter I think a private Charter for
between here in New York round trip is
like 10 to 13 000.
James is
at that this level I've explained to a
lot of people there's no way someone
with a workload of James O'Keefe is
going to drive the six or seven hours
down here to come on the show or drive
back or wait in the airport and dedicate
a whole day or two to travel he's like
hey I've got a bunch of meetings today I
can go on Temple show we got to get a
private Charter we step in we get the
plane we're there in an hour boom we're
gone we're back in New York the next day
to certain levels of of work and
responsibility require things like this
now don't get me wrong like when the
global Elites are like oh there's
climate change is a big problem but
they're gonna fly in private jets yeah
we can criticize that I'm not going to
criticize someone for saying the only
way I can do this is if I if I get a
private Charter yeah I don't think the
logistics of his career are that
unreasonable especially if he has that
much to do I mean he has a a ton of risk
because he's just like a non-profit
leader he is a public face people are
very angry with the work that he does
there is more of a Target on his back uh
and I will say I think this is uh sort
of the the problem with nonprofits I
think a lot of people start nonprofits
because they see you know people can
donate to me and it's a tax write-off
and then I can get support I don't know
how I would make money off of this but I
do want to dedicate my life it's very
Mission driven but uh nonprofits are
ultimately ruled by a board and that can
be detrimental as we saw and they
betrayed him thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time